Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Play with your fancies, and then behold upon the hemp and tackle shipboys climbing. Hear the shrill whistle, which doth order give to sounds confused. Behold the thread and sails, born with invisible and creeping wind, draw the huge bottoms through the furrowed sea breasting the lofty surge oh do but think you stand upon the rivage and behold a city on the inconstant billows dancing for so appears this fleet majestical holding due course to Hafla. Follow, follow.
谢谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。任凭你们放飞幻想，然后凝视着攀爬在大麻绳缆上的水手们。听那尖锐的哨声，它在纷乱的杂音中下达指令。看那初生于无形而潜行之风中的绳索与风帆，拉动着巨大的船底划过犁沟般的海面，顶着高耸的巨浪——哦，只需想象你们正站在河岸上，看着一座城市在变幻无常的波涛上起舞。因为这支雄伟的舰队正是如此，正沿着通往阿夫勒尔（Hafla）的正道航行。跟随，跟随。
So that was the chorus in William Shakespeare's Henry V and describing the departure of the English fleet for the mouth of the River Seine. And to recap from last time, Tom, Henry V, in his late 20s, this austere, deeply dedicated, serious, slightly terrifying warlord. I think very terrifying, let's be honest. Well, he's not terrifying if you're English. I think he is quite terrifying, even if you're English.
那是威廉·莎士比亚的《亨利五世》中的合唱，描述了英国舰队出发前往塞纳河口的情景。为了回顾一下上期内容，汤姆，当时年近20多岁的亨利五世，是一个严厉、极其专注、严肃、略带恐怖的军阀。老实说，我觉得是非常恐怖。好吧，如果你是英国人，他并不可怖。我觉得他相当可怖，哪怕你是英国人。
I think he's inspiring. Well, we'll find out how and why he's terrifying if you're English later on. He has set off across the channel, his destination, Harfleur, a nest of pirates who are state-sponsored pirates i suppose it's fair to say this is going to be his first target on the french mainland his ambition is not just to capture harfleur but is to use harfleur as the springboard for a wider campaign in france to capitalize on the chaos there and initially to annex the formerly English territory of Normandy. But Tom, like a man invading Russia, he has made a mistake, hasn't he?
我觉得他很激励人心。好吧，我们稍后会发现，如果你是英国人，他到底是如何以及为什么可怖的。他已经起航横渡海峡，目的地是阿夫勒尔（Harfleur），这是一群海盗的老巢，一群有国家支持的海盗，我想这样说挺公道的，这将是他在法国本土的第一个目标。他的野心不仅是攻克阿夫勒尔，而是以阿夫勒尔为跳板，在法国发起更大规模的战役，利用那里的混乱，首先吞并前英国领土诺曼底。但汤姆，就像一个入侵俄罗斯的人一样，他犯了一个错误，不是吗？
He's started too late in the year. So it's already mid-August by the time they land at Hafler, which means that Henry, I mean, he needs to capture the town very, very quickly because otherwise, as you say, it'll be too late. Autumn will be coming on. He needs to crack on. So he's in the mouth of the Seine in this kind of great bay. And as we described at the end of the last episode, there's this rocky beach, there's a shallow cliff, there's a kind of plateau and Harfleur is three miles away. And Henry has chosen it because it is so unexpected. It is therefore unlikely to be guarded.
他一年中开始得太晚了。所以当他们登陆阿夫勒尔时，已经是八月中旬了，这意味着亨利——我的意思是，他需要非常非常快地攻下这座城镇，否则，正如你所说，就太迟了。秋天就要来了。他得加把劲。所以他在这个大海湾里的塞纳河口。正如我们在上一集末尾所描述的，这里有一片岩石海滩，有一处低矮的悬崖，有一个类似高原的地方，而阿夫勒尔就在三英里外。亨利选择这里是因为它太出人意料了。因此，它很可能没有受到防守。
But of course, he needs to be sure. And so he turns to a Holland, I'm very proud to say. Specifically, the 19-year-old John Holland, who is the son of the Duke of Exeter, who'd been a half-brother of Richard II and had been embroiled in the first great conspiracy against Henry IV back in Epiphany 1400. And he'd been executed. So poor John Holland hadn't been allowed to inherit his father's titles, but he's hoping to create a good impression on this campaign and maybe get them. And he does create a good impression. And I'm happy to say that he actually gets his titles the following year.
但当然，他需要确凿的把握。于是他求助于一个荷兰人（a Holland），我很骄傲地说。具体来说，是19岁的约翰·霍兰（John Holland），他是埃克塞特公爵（Duke of Exeter）的儿子，埃克塞特公爵曾是理查二世（Richard II）的同母异父兄弟，并曾卷入1400年主显节前后针对亨利四世的第一次大阴谋。他被处决了。所以可怜的约翰·霍兰未能继承他父亲的头衔，但他希望在这场战役中留下好印象，也许能拿回这些头衔。他也确实留下了好印象。我很高兴地说，他在第二年真的得到了他的头衔。
So that's good to know. And so he goes back and says, yeah, all clear. And so the landings begin and you have these shallow kind of barges which have been brought over the channel and men and horses are loaded into them. And then they come crunching up onto the rocky beach. And the whole process takes three days and as anyone knows from later Normandy landings on D-Day it's the landing that is always the most dangerous particularly if you're being attacked so the fact that the English
所以这倒是个好消息。于是他回去说，是的，一切安全。登陆开始了，你看到这些被运过海峡的浅底驳船，士兵和马匹被装载进去。然后它们冲上了布满岩石的海滩。整个过程花了三天时间，正如任何人从后来诺曼底登陆日的登陆所知道的那样，登陆总是最危险的，特别是当你遭到攻击的时候，所以英国人
are not attacked this is a good start for the campaign. Because the French don't know that they're there? They've been taken by surprise? No, they don't. And it's too late to marshal the resources that would enable them to oppose the landing. So on the 17th of August, three days after the landing, Henry is ready to advance on Harfleur and he invests the city on the western side, which is the side nearest the landing point, and he's occupying the heights kind of above the city and on the evening of the following day he wants to invest the heights that stand on the other side so on the eastern side and so he sends his brother the duke of clarence with a large part of the english army to do that so that they will then be on both sides of harfleur it's actually a tricky task
没有遭到攻击，这对战役来说是个好消息。因为法国人不知道他们在那儿？他们被打了个措手不及？不，他们不知道。而且要调集能够让他们抵抗登陆的资源已经太迟了。所以在8月17日，登陆三天后，亨利准备向阿夫勒尔推进，他在西侧——也就是离登陆点最近的那一侧——对这座城市实施了合围，他占领了城市上方的高地，并在第二天傍晚，他想要合围另一侧——也就是东侧——的高地，于是他派遣他的弟弟克拉伦斯公爵（Duke of Clarence）带着英国军队的大部分人马去完成这个任务，这样他们就会处于阿夫勒尔的两侧。这其实是个棘手的任务，
because harfleur has this river the the Les Arts, which flows through it. And on the south side, it flows through kind of mud flats. And when the tide comes in, these mud flats and the Les Arts itself kind of vanish beneath the waters and the waves reach all the way up to the walls of Harfleur. But on the north side, you know, you've got this river valley and the Les Arts has flooded the river valley. So it's all very marshy and swampy. You know, you've got this river valley and the Lazard has flooded the river valley. So it's all very marshy and swampy. And so Clarence and his men, it takes them basically kind of, you know, they have to walk nine or ten miles to avoid the floods. And it's not until dawn on the 19th that Clarence's men appear on the crest of the far hills from Henry's side.
因为阿夫勒尔有一条莱萨尔河（the Les Arts）穿城而过。在南侧，它流经泥滩。当潮水上涨时，这些泥滩和莱萨尔河本身就会在水面和波浪下消失，海浪一直拍打到阿夫勒尔的城墙。但在北侧，你知道的，有这个河谷，莱萨尔河淹没了河谷。所以一切都非常泥泞和沼泽化。你知道的，有这个河谷，莱萨尔河淹没了河谷。所以一切都非常泥泞和沼泽化。因此，克拉伦斯和他的手下，基本上花了他们大约——你知道的，他们不得不走九到十英里来避开洪水。直到19日黎明，克拉伦斯的手下才出现在从亨利这边望过去的远山山脊上。
And the town is now effectively sealed off because you've got the tidal estuary on the other side. You've got this river valley. There is no way anyone can approach it. The English completely control access. And this is very bad news for Havelaar because its defences aren't really very strong. It's an important city. So it's on the site of where La Havre is now. It's kind of been swallowed up by La Havre's industrial zone. And in the early 15th century, it covers about 20 hectares, population of around 4,500, 5,000 perhaps. And its walls stretch for two and a half miles. But these walls are about 70 years old. They haven't been repaired. The French haven't really thought that it's going to be attacked. And so because the French haven't been anticipating an English attack, there aren't that many men. I mean, the garrisons may be, by some estimates, as low as 35, with a few crossbowmen who were there as well. And they haven't really stocked up on provisions. And to make things worse for the people of Harfleur, the Duke of Clarence, while he was marching around to take up his position on the opposite heights to Henry,
现在这座城镇实际上已经被封锁了，因为另一边有潮汐河口，还有这个河谷。任何人都不可能靠近它。英国人完全控制了出入通道。这对阿夫勒尔来说是个非常坏的消息，因为它的防御其实不是很强。这是一座重要的城市。所以它的位置就是现在勒阿弗尔（Le Havre）所在的地方。它有点被勒阿弗尔的工业区吞没了。在15世纪初，它占地约20公顷，人口大约4,500人，也许5,000人。它的城墙绵延两英里半。但这些城墙大约有70年的历史了。它们没有得到修缮。法国人根本没料到它会被攻击。正因为法国人没有料到英国的进攻，所以没有多少人。我的意思是，据某些估计，驻军可能少至35人，还有一些驻扎在那里的弩手。而且他们也没有真正囤积粮草。为了让阿夫勒尔人民的处境雪上加霜，克拉伦斯公爵在绕行到与亨利相对的高地就位时，
had captured a wagon train with provisions and indeed some cannon. So this is bad. Yeah, but there's an interesting, not paradox, I'm not sure what the word is, an irony or something. Henry has landed in a kingdom that he believes is his own. So Harfleur is the first target. And this is the first test, I suppose, because is he going to come as a rampaging king of England, fighting his ancestral enemies, or is he arriving as le bon papa? It's a reference from our French Revolution series to Louis XVI. Is he the
截获了一支装有粮草和几门大炮的辎重车队。所以这很糟糕。是的，但这里有一个有趣的——不是悖论，我不确定该用哪个词，一个讽刺还是什么的。亨利登陆了一个他认为是属于他自己的王国。所以阿夫勒尔是第一个目标。这也是第一次考验，我想，因为他是要作为一个横行霸道的英格兰国王、与祖传敌人作战而到来，还是作为一个“好爸爸”（le bon papa）抵达？这是我们法国大革命系列中提到路易十六的一个典故。他是一个
benevolent French king returning to his own inheritance? Well, what's a promising sign for the people of Fafleur is that when Henry lands, he does not unfurl his banner. And if he'd unfurled his banner, that would be a sign that, you know, pile in, crack on, loot and pillage and do everything you want. He doesn't do that. And he issues various ordinances of war that there are to be no attacks on churches or priests or on women and no setting fire to crops, no incineration of buildings. To that extent, he is the King of France. He's looking after his subjects. And listeners may be tempted to view this with scepticism. But I think that these ordinances of war, Henry is going to uphold them because you said he's not a particularly
返回自己祖传领地的仁慈的法国国王吗？好吧，对阿夫勒尔人民来说一个有希望的迹象是，当亨利登陆时，他没有展开他的旗帜。如果他展开了旗帜，那将是一个信号，意味着——冲进去，加油，大肆搜掠、劫掠，做你想做的任何事。他没有这样做。他发布了各种战争条例，规定不得攻击教堂或神职人员，不得攻击妇女，不得焚烧庄稼，不得焚烧建筑物。从这个意义上说，他是法国国王。他在照顾他的子民。听众可能会对此抱持怀疑态度。但我认为，这些战争条例，亨利将会执行它们，因为正如你所说，他对英国人来说并不是一个特别
intimidating figure to the English. I think he is because he is going to punish infractions. So even before he'd set sail from England, a group of Lancastrian archermen had been coming south to join the expedition and they had passed through my native town of Salisbury, where they behaved disgracefully and attacked the locals and killed four of them. And they were very, very severely punished. So that's an example of what will happen if Henry's troops do not obey these ordinances. I think he's doing this both because he thinks it's his duty, you know, his God-ordained duty, but also because he genuinely has hopes of winning the French round. You know, we mentioned in the previous episode,
具有威慑力的人物。我认为他是，因为他会惩罚违规行为。甚至在他从英格兰启航之前，一群兰开斯特（Lancastrian）弓箭手正向南赶来加入远征军，他们途经我的家乡索尔兹伯里（Salisbury），在那里他们表现恶劣，袭击了当地人并杀害了四个人。他们受到了非常非常严厉的惩罚。所以这就是如果亨利军队不遵守这些条例将会发生的事情的一个例子。我认为他这样做既是因为他认为这是他的职责，你知道的，上帝赋予他的职责，也是因为他真心希望赢得法国人的支持。你知道的，我们在上一集提到过，
Henry is kind of admired by people in France, but probably not by the people of our fleur, who find themselves surrounded by his cannon and his archers. They are not in a mood to accept the fact that he's actually the king of France and they should surrender to him. So they defy him. And that, of course, means that, in Henry's opinion, they are now rebels against their anointed king.
亨利在法国挺受人们钦佩的，但可能不受阿夫勒尔人民的钦佩，他们发现自己被他的大炮和弓箭手包围了。他们才不接受他是真正的法国国王、他们应该向他投降这一事实。所以他们违抗他。当然，这意味着在亨利看来，他们现在成了他们受膏国王的叛军。
In that case, they're fair game. They are fair game. And so the assault on Harfleur is a bloody, brutal battle, isn't it? It really is, yes. And it's the first Norman town to be pulverized by artillery of course it won't be the last right and there's a french account which describes henry's cannon as being of monstrous size spewing out great boulders amid clouds of thick smoke and a noise like the fires of hell and so the once more under the breach speech that henry gives you know this famous that you delivered so beautifully in
既然如此，他们就是合法的攻击目标。他们是合法的攻击目标。所以对阿夫勒尔的进攻是一场血腥、残酷的战斗，不是吗？确实如此，是的。而且它是第一座被火炮粉碎的诺曼底城镇，当然它不会是最后一座，对吧？有一个法国记载描述亨利的火炮体型巨大，在浓烟滚滚中喷射出巨大的巨石，声音犹如地狱之火，所以再次印证了亨利发表的“冲向缺口”的演讲，你知道的，这个著名的、你在上一集里
the previous episode it's actually pretty accurate because it is all about using the cannon to blast holes in the walls and then English soldiers forcing their way through the breach. But the problem for Henry is that all the rubble and the devastation means that there is raw material for the citizens of Harfleur to use to patch up every breach. So actually the siege is going on longer than he'd hoped and it's having to inflict more damage on Harfleur than Henry had hoped. Because of course what he wants is to make it into a kind of second Calais, an English stronghold.
声情并茂发表的演讲，其实相当准确，因为它讲的就是用大炮在城墙上轰出缺口，然后英国士兵强行冲过缺口。但对亨利来说问题在于，所有的瓦砾和满目疮痍意味着阿夫勒尔市民有现成的原材料用来修补每一个缺口。所以实际上，围城战持续的时间比他希望的长，而且它对阿夫勒尔造成的破坏比亨利希望的大。因为当然，他想要的是把它变成第二个加来（Calais），一个英国的据点。
And if he's smashing the walls and pulverising all the buildings, then that's really bad. He's going to have to repair it. And it also means that if he captures it and there are great holes in the wall, then the city will be very vulnerable to recapture. So all of this is bad news. And there is also further bad news for Henry, which is, as Anne Currie, the doyen of Agincourt historians, puts it,
如果他把城墙砸碎，把所有建筑物都炸成粉末，那可就太糟糕了。他将不得不修复它。这也意味着，如果他攻占了它而城墙上有巨大的破洞，那么这座城市将非常容易被夺回。所以所有这些都是坏消息。对亨利来说还有更多坏消息，正如阿让库尔（Agincourt）历史学界的泰斗安·柯里（Anne Curry）所说，
that Henry had too large an army for the purpose. And what she means by that is that they are forced to camp in quite marshy and therefore pestilential areas. You know, this is this flood plain. And so it's not a good place to be. And sickness starts to spread through the English camp. And Thomas Walsingham, the monk at St. Albans, he talks about how there are fetid corpses of animals who've been drowned in the flooding, who are kind of floating down. And this is not a good sign, you know, if you're camped out. There are also reports that the English eat underripe grapes, which is not good for the bowels, and shellfish. Yeah, you don't want to mess with the shellfish. Yeah, so people fall very ill.
亨利为了这个目的带的军队太多了。她这话的意思是，他们被迫扎营在相当泥泞、因而充满瘟疫的地区。你知道的，这是泛滥平原。所以这不是个好地方。疾病开始在英格兰军营中蔓延。圣奥尔本斯（St. Albans）的修士托马斯·沃尔辛厄姆（Thomas Walsingham）谈到，洪水中淹死的动物的恶臭尸体顺流漂下。如果你在野外扎营，这可不是什么好兆头，你知道的。还有报道称英国人吃未成熟的葡萄，这不利于肠道健康，还有贝类。对，你可别去碰贝类。是的，所以人们病得很重。
The Duke of Clarence among them, the Earl of Arundel, Henry's great friend, he falls sick. All this raises the issue that it's all very well to be great at fighting battles and to have loads of archers, but an assault on France requires you have to supply your army and keep it supplied and healthy. You do. A long way from your native land. So there is no supply chain, I guess, once you go inland into
克拉伦斯公爵也在其中，阿伦德尔伯爵（Earl of Arundel）——亨利的好友——也病倒了。所有这一切引发了一个问题：擅长打仗、拥有大量弓箭手是一回事，但进攻法国要求你必须向军队提供补给，并保证补给充足且士兵健康。确实如此。离你的祖国很远。所以一旦你深入法国腹地，就没有补给线了，我想。
France. So that's going to be a problem for Henry further down the line, isn't it? It absolutely is. And of course, it's also difficult to replace men who you've lost a disease, which is by now starting to sweep the English camp. And so the people of Harfleur managed to hold out for four weeks weeks which is much longer than Henry had been anticipating and by mid-September finally it's clear that the end is clear they've run out of food they've had high casualties from Henry's artillery and even those who are not being wounded by arrow fire or cannonballs are falling sick because disease is sweeping the city as well and so on the 15th of September,
所以这会在以后给亨利带来麻烦，不是吗？绝对会。当然，补充在因病（此时已开始席卷英格兰军营）而减员的士兵也很困难。因此，阿夫勒尔的人民设法坚守了四周，这比亨利预期的要长得多。到了9月中旬，很明显，结局就要明朗了，他们的食物已经耗尽，亨利的火炮造成了大量伤亡，甚至那些没有被箭雨或炮弹击伤的人也病倒了，因为疾病也在城内肆虐。所以在9月15日，
they send a message to Clarence in his camp asking for a three-week truce. And Clarence says, no, but you can have three days. And on the 18th of September, the garrison agrees that it will surrender in four days time. So on the 22nd of September at one o'clock in the afternoon, if no French relief force has come. And Henry accepts this and no relief comes. And so at one o'clock on the 22nd of September, all the captains and the leading citizens of Harfleur walk out in sombre procession and they walk to Henry V who is in his tent and he keeps them waiting on their knees for a long time before he will even look at them. And the mayor of the city has the keys of the town and
他们给克拉伦斯的军营带信，请求停战三周。克拉伦斯说，不行，但可以给三天。9月18日，守军同意在四天后投降。也就是9月22日下午一点，如果没有法国的解围部队赶到的话。亨利接受了这一点，也没有援军到来。所以在9月22日下午一点，阿夫勒尔所有的船长和主要市民排成沉重的队伍走出来，他们走向身处帐篷中的亨利五世，而亨利让他们在地上跪了很久，才肯看他们一眼。城市的市长拿着镇上的钥匙，
he hands them over to the king and the city has now surrendered apart from a tiny group of holdouts who continue to hold out in the tower for a few more days. And the king says he will not, as he feels entitled to, completely annihilate them. But his terms are pretty brutal. The garrison are to be treated as prisoners of war. The old and infirm are expelled and the women and children are given the option of either staying or kind of leaving the town, probably heading for Rouen. And Henry isn't being cruel here. He's essentially giving them the chance to get out of a place that is a hellhole, basically. It's been a scene of war, there's disease and everything. So he gives them money if they want to go. So this is the end of September. It's gone on much longer than he
把它交给了国王，这座城市现在已经投降了，除了极少数在塔里继续死守了几天的人。国王表示，他不会像他觉得有权做的那样彻底消灭他们。但他的条件相当残酷。守军将被当作战俘对待。老弱病残被驱逐，妇女和儿童可以选择留下来或离开城镇，可能是前往鲁昂（Rouen）。亨利在这里并不是残酷。他基本上是给他们一个机会，离开这个简直是人间地狱的地方。这里一直是战区，有疾病等等。所以如果他们想走，他会给他们钱。所以这是9月底。战事比他
thought. Autumn is coming in after winter. He's lost already some of his men have been lost, presumably killed in the siege or to disease. Halfler is a definite victory for England. I mean, it's a feather in his cap. So the French at this point, you know, they've suffered this great humiliation, I guess, of Henry landing on their coast. I think it is seen as a humiliation across France. Right. Yes. And what are they going to do about it? Well, it's not just that it's been lost, but that no attempt was made to relieve it. And so, of course, in situations like this, you always have the blame game.
想象的要长得多。冬天过后秋天就要来了。他已经损失了一些人，据推测是在围城战中阵亡或死于疾病。对英格兰来说，阿夫勒尔是一场绝对的胜利。我的意思是，这是他帽子上的一根羽毛。所以在这一点上，法国人，你知道的，他们遭受了亨利登陆其海岸的巨大耻辱。我认为这在整个法国都被视为一种耻辱。没错。是的。他们打算怎么做？好吧，不仅是失守了，而且根本没有采取任何救援行动。所以，当然，在这种情况下，你总是免不了互相指责。
And the guy who is chiefly blamed for it is our friend, the Duke of Alençon, who listeners may remember from the previous episode. He's the bruiser, the boar-like figure who is always a man for charging in. So it might be thought it's surprising that he didn't lead the attack. I think it's just that he didn't have enough resources available to him and the attack came as a surprise. So he's dismissed as the commander-in-chief in
主要被归咎的那个人是我们的朋友阿朗松公爵（Duke of Alençon），听众可能从上一集里还记得他。他是那个好斗的、像野猪一样的人物，总是冲锋陷阵。所以人们可能会觉得奇怪，为什么他没有领导进攻。我想这只是因为他没有足够的可用资源，而且进攻来得太突然。所以他被解除了诺曼底总司令的职务，
Normandy and he is replaced by the most famous soldier, maybe not just in France, but in the whole of Christendom. And this is Marshal Boussico, who we last met holding the lists at St. Angliver, the most famous tournament in late 14th century history, where he had fought with the future Henry IV and with Hotspur. And he's had a tremendous career. So he fought at the great Christian defeat at Nicopolis in 1396 against the Turks, where he'd performed very, very creditably and ended up being ransomed. He then helped the Roman emperor, the Byzantine emperor, Emmanuel II, against the Turkish siege of Constantinople. He'd come back to France.
接替他的是也许不仅在法国、而且在整个基督教世界最著名的军人。这就是布锡科元帅（Marshal Boussico），我们上次见到他时，他正在圣安格利韦（St. Angliver）——14th世纪末历史上最著名的比武大会——上维护秩序，他曾与未来的亨利四世以及热刺（Hotspur）交过手。他的职业生涯极为辉煌。他曾在1396年土耳其人对基督徒的重大失败——尼科波利斯（Nicopolis）战役中作战，他在那里的表现非常非常出色，并最终被赎回。随后他协助罗马皇帝、拜占庭皇帝曼努埃尔二世（Emmanuel II）抵御土耳其人对君士坦丁堡的围攻。他回到了法国。
He'd founded a chivalric order dedicated to the ideals of courtly love. He's basically a complete legend. Right. Okay. He's the absolute model of what a French knight would want to be. The French, I think even more than the English, are obsessed by Arthurian romance. Loads of French knights, I mean, unlike the English, are named after Arthurian. So you get loads of people who are called Lancelot or Percival or Galahadda or whatever, whereas the English all tend to be called William or Edward English are named after Arthurians. So you get loads of people who are called Lancelot or Percival or Galahad or whatever, whereas the English all tend to be called William or Edward
他创立了一个致力于纯洁爱（courtly love）理想的骑士团。他基本上是一个绝对的传奇人物。好吧。他就是法国骑士梦寐以求的绝对楷模。法国人，我认为甚至比英国人更痴迷于亚瑟王传奇。大量的法国骑士——与英国人不同——都是以亚瑟王的名字命名的。所以你会看到大量名叫兰斯洛特（Lancelot）、珀西瓦尔（Percival）、加拉哈德（Galahad）之类的人，而英国人往往都叫威廉或爱德华，英国人都是以亚瑟王的名字命名的。所以你会看到大量名叫兰斯洛特、珀西瓦尔、加拉哈德之类的人，而英国人往往都叫威廉或爱德华
or whatever. Yeah, or worse, Thomas. I mean, that's a tremendous name. You can't argue with that. So the fact that Bouticot is coming in, this great hero, this paladin of France, this is a sign that the French are taking the invasion seriously. So also is the fact that in the last week of August, a royal proclamation had been issued proclaiming a general summons across the whole of France, calling people to throw the English back into the sea. And the Dauphin, despite being a late riser... You said he was too fat. Yeah, he's a bit podgy. He's come to Normandy to serve as the captain general. I mean, basically, he's a figurehead because he's inexperienced. Unlike Henry, when he was a teenager, he hasn't been off fighting.
或者别的什么。是的，或者更糟，托马斯。我的意思是，那是个了不起的名字。你对此无可反驳。所以布锡科的到来，这位伟大的英雄，这位法国的帕拉丁（paladin，圣骑士），这是一个信号，表明法国人正在严肃对待这次入侵。同样地，在8月的最后一周，一项皇家公告发布了，在全法国范围内发出总动员令，号召人们把英国人赶回海里去。王太子（Dauphin），尽管起得很晚……你说过他太胖了。是的，他有点胖乎乎的。他来到诺曼底担任总队长。我的意思是，基本上他只是个傀儡，因为他缺乏经验。与亨利在青少年时期就出去打仗不同，
He's been lounging around in bed ogling girls. But he's come, so that's credit to him. He's actually in quite poor health as well. So he's not an ideal figure. But it's good for morale to have the Dauphin there, of course. The real commander, the guy who is in charge overall, so who Boussico answers to and who is the power behind the Dauphin's throne, is another professional soldier like Boussico. So a guy who has devoted his whole life to the art of warfare. And he is the constable of France, the kind of the
他一直在床上闲逛、冲女孩子抛媚眼。但他来了，所以这算他的功劳。其实他的健康状况也相当糟糕。所以他不是个理想的人物。但有王太子在那里对士气很有好处，当然。真正的指挥官、全盘负责的人——也就是布锡科要向其汇报、并成为王太子宝座背后实权人物的人——是另一位像布锡科一样的职业军人。也就是说，一个把一生都奉献给战争艺术的人。他是法国统帅（constable of France），也就是
leading military figure. And this is a man called Charles d'Aubray. And he is the constable of France, the kind of the leading military figure. And this is a man called Charles d'Abray. And he has been fighting the English for a very, very long time. So he's old enough to have fought against them under Bertrand de Guesclin, who was the French military leader who essentially had thrown the English out of France back in the latter days of Edward III. He's basically on the Armagnac side. So he'd been dismissed as constable by John the Fearless when John the Fearless was in power. And then when John was chased out of Paris, Charles d'Albray had been given back his office as a constable. So Boussico and d'Albray are both very competent soldiers. They don't want to just rush in. They
主要的军事统帅。这个人名叫夏尔·德·阿尔布雷（Charles d'Albret）。他是法国统帅，主要的军事统帅。这个人名叫夏尔·德·阿尔布雷。他与英国人作战的时间非常非常长。所以他的年纪足够大，曾在贝特朗·杜·盖克兰（Bertrand de Guesclin）手下与他们作战，后者是法国军事领袖，曾在爱德华三世的晚期基本上把英国人赶出了法国。他基本上属于阿尔马尼亚克（Armagnac）派系。所以当无畏约翰（John the Fearless）掌权时，他被无畏约翰解除了统帅职务。然后当无畏约翰被逐出巴黎时，夏尔·德·阿尔布雷恢复了统帅职务。所以布锡科和阿尔布雷都是非常称职的军人。他们不想贸然出击。他们
want to concentrate as large a force of manpower as they can possibly get. They hope to relieve Harfleur by mid-September, but it's in mid-September that Harfleur falls. And so now they have a massive force. But if Henry decides to skedaddle back to England, they can then move on Harfleur and hopefully recapture it because the walls are all pockmarked. And for Henry, this is a huge problem because all he has to show for all this money,
希望尽可能多地集结兵力。他们希望在9月中旬前为阿夫勒尔解围，但正是在9月中旬，阿夫勒尔陷落了。所以现在他们拥有了一支庞大的军队。但如果亨利决定溜回英格兰，他们就可以进军阿夫勒尔，并希望将其夺回，因为城墙已经千疮百孔了。对亨利来说，这是一个巨大的问题，因为他倾注了所有的金钱、
all this manpower, all this effort is a kind of devastated single French port. Okay. So he's got this port. He's lost his mental disease. Two of the big wigs in his expedition, so Clarence and Arundel,
所有的兵力、所有的努力，换来的却只是一座满目疮痍的单一法国港口。好吧。他得到了这个港口。他失去了心理健康。他远征军中的两位大人物——克拉伦斯和阿伦德尔，
they actually have to go home because they are invalided out. Yeah, and Arundel dies a few days after landing in England. The clock is ticking towards the end of 1415. He's obviously not going to take Normandy by the end of the year. So he could go home, and he doesn't go home, does he, because he thinks that would be humiliating. That's not enough of a return. What does he do now? That's the question.
由于伤病被遣送回国，实际上不得不回家。是的，阿伦德尔在登陆英格兰几天后就去世了。1415年接近尾声的倒计时已经开始。他显然无法在年底前拿下诺曼底。所以他可以回家，但他没有回家，不是吗？因为他觉得那样太屈辱了。这还不足以构成回报。他现在要做什么？这是个问题。
Well, the first thing he does is challenge the Dauphin to a duel, which unsurprisingly the Dauphin's not very keen. So a description of the Dauphin at this time from someone who was in his train, the Dauphin was fat in his body, heavy and slow and not at all agile. So I think if that's your level of training, you wouldn't want to go head to head with Henry. The Dauphin is not dual body ready. He is not dual body ready, no. So when the option for having a duel is thrown back in his teeth, Henry decides that what he will do instead, rather than sail back to England, is he will march from Huffler across northern France to the other port that England holds, which is Calais. And he will then sail back to England from Calais.
嗯，他做的第一件事就是向王太子下战书要求决斗，毫无疑问，王太子对此并不热衷。以下是当时他随行人员对王太子的描述：王太子身体发胖，沉重迟钝，一点也不敏捷。所以我想，如果那是你的训练水平，你绝不会想与亨利正面交锋。王太子还没有做好决斗的身体准备。他没有做好决斗的身体准备，是的。因此，当决斗的选择被原封不动地抛回给他时，亨利决定他要做的不是乘船回英格兰，而是从阿夫勒尔出发，穿过法国北部，前往英国控制的另一个港口——加来。然后他将从加来乘船回英格兰。
And what's the point of this march? It has several advantages. So the first is it spares him the embarrassment of leaving for England early. By going across France, he's making a public proclamation of the fact that there is nowhere within his kingdom that he cannot visit. He has the right to go where he wishes.
这场行军的意义何在？它有几个优点。首先，它免去了他提早回英格兰的尴尬。通过穿过法国，他是在向公众宣告，在他的王国里没有他去不了的地方。他有权去他想去的地方。
It means that he can leave his fleet at Harfleur to keep the garrison there supplied with building materials and with more men and with food. So that's important because he cannot afford to lose Harfleur. And of course, it also means on that score that if he's marching across France, then the likelihood is that this vast French force, which is gathering, will go for him rather than for Haveler. Well, that's the key thing, isn't it? So he's a kind of decoy. He's drawing the French army away from his one captured city, his one prize. And maybe he'll
这意味着他可以把舰队留在阿夫勒尔，为那里的守军提供建筑材料、更多的人员和食物。这很重要，因为他承担不起失去阿夫勒尔的代价。当然，这也意味着，如果他正在穿过法国行军，那么正在集结的庞大法军很有可能会去攻击他，而不是去攻击阿夫勒尔。嗯，这才是关键所在，不是吗？所以他成了一种诱饵。他把法国军队从他唯一攻占的城市、他唯一的战利品身边引开。也许他能
get to Calais and be able to spend the winter in Calais. Is that what he's thinking? No, he'll sail back. When he gets to Calais, he'll sail back and he'll be able to give a good talk. I've captured Harfleur. I've marched through France. They couldn't stop me. It's great. But my hunch is, and we have no way of knowing this, but my hunch is also that Henry suspects
到达加来，并能够在加来过冬？他是这么想的吗？不，他会乘船回去。当他到达加来时，他会乘船回去，并且能够好好吹嘘一番。我攻占了阿夫勒尔。我穿过了法国。他们阻止不了我。这太棒了。但我的直觉是——虽然我们无法确知——但我的直觉也是，亨利怀疑
that he will get a battle. And I think that he alone, maybe in the entire expedition, wants this. And he wants it, I think, because he thinks he will win this battle for all the reasons that we looked at in the entire expedition wants this. And he wants it, I think, because he thinks he will win this battle for all the reasons that we looked at in the previous episode. But also, I think because as the Christian king that he is, he wants to put it to the test. He wants to reassure himself that God is on his side, that he is entitled to the throne of France.
他会迎来一场战斗。而且我认为，可能在整支远征军中，只有他一个人渴望这场战斗。我认为他渴望它，是因为他坚信自己会赢得这场战斗，原因就是我们在上一集里探讨过的那些原因。但我也认为，作为他那样的基督教国王，他想检验一下。他想向自己保证上帝是站在他这一边的，他有权登上法国王位。
He knows that God is on his side. God's an instrument. Well, I think that that is why he's prepared to take this enormous risk, because it is a huge risk. There is this vast army accumulating. He knows that if he's cornered and defeated, disaster will follow. I mean, he'll either be killed or maybe, you know, from England's point of view, even worse, captured, because that would then bleed England dry, or maybe alternatively precipitate a coup against the absent Henry, the collapse of the Lancastrian regime. So the stakes are now even higher than they were when he was setting sail from England earlier in the year. And that's why a large majority of his council, when he summons them and says this is his plan, they urge him not to do it. And Clarence,
他知道上帝站在他这一边。上帝是一个工具。嗯，我想这就是为什么他准备冒这个巨大的险，因为它确实是个巨大的风险。这支庞大的军队正在集结。他知道如果他被逼入绝境并被打败，灾难就会接踵而至。我的意思是，他要么被杀，或者从英格兰的角度来看更糟糕的是被俘，因为那将使英格兰血流成河，或者交替引发针对不在国内的亨利的政变、兰斯/.斯特政权的崩溃。所以现在赌注比他今年早些时候从英格兰起航时还要高。正因如此，当他召集议会并宣布这是他的计划时，绝大多数议员都敦促他不要这么做。克拉伦斯——
his brother, I mean, is very, very insistent. He's sick. He's about to leave home. He's obviously not in a good mood. He doesn't feel that the expedition is going well, but he's very, very blunt. He warns Henry to consider the great and infinite multitude of their enemies, which then were assembled to prevent and hinder the king's passage by land, whereof by their spies they had knowledge. So they know what is brewing. But Henry decides, no, I'm going to risk it. And so on the 8th of October, which I think not coincidentally is the feast day
他的弟弟，我的意思是，非常非常坚持。他病了。他就要回家了。他显然心情不好。他觉得远征进展不顺，但他非常非常直率。他警告亨利要考虑敌人那“巨大而无限的多样性”，敌人当时已经集结，企图通过陆路阻止和妨碍国王的通行，他们的谍报人员对此早已知晓。所以他们知道正在酝酿什么。但亨利决定，不，我要冒这个险。于是，在10月8日——我认为绝非巧合的是，这一天是法国主保圣人圣德尼（Saint-Denis）的节日——他离开了阿夫勒尔前往加来。关于他随身携带了多少人，人们争论不休，我们稍后会谈到这一点，但大约有6,000人。无论如何都不是一支庞大的军队。
of the patron saint of France, Saint-Denis, he leaves Huffler for Calais. There is debate about how many men he has with him and we'll come to this in due course, but probably about 6,000 men. Not a massive army by any means. Of whom about 5,000 are archers, so he's only got 1,000 men at arms. Yeah. To face a French army, that's not many.
其中大约5,000人是弓箭手，所以他只有1,000名重装骑兵。是的。要面对一支法国军队，这人数可真不多。
And off he sets, and effectively the ball is now in the court of the French. The ball is in the French court, Tom. That tennis ball analogy again. What is going to happen? Will the French return serve with a vengeance? Find out after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
于是他出发了，实际上球现在传到了法国人这边。球到了法国人那边，汤姆。又用回那个网球比喻了。接下来会发生什么？法国人会发起猛烈的回击吗？中场休息后为您揭晓。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, a splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及少许八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Also, most high and powerful prince, and my most honoured and gracious lord, of the news of these parts, may it please your lordship to know that by the arrival of divers good friends repairing to this town and marches, as well from France as from Flanders, it is generally reported to me that without doubt the king, our Lord, will be fought by his adversaries within 15 days from this time at the latest. And it is said that the Duke of Lorraine, amongst others, has already assembled 50,000 men and that when they all meet, there will not be less than 100,000 or more. So that was William Bardolph, the Lieutenant Governor of Calais, and he was writing to Henry V's brother, the Duke of Bedford, who listeners may remember was left
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。另，至高无上的亲王殿下，我最尊敬和仁慈的领主，关于各地的消息，愿阁下得知，随着多位挚友前来本镇及边境，不论来自法国还是佛兰德斯（Flanders），普遍有传闻向我报告说，毫无疑问，我们的国王陛下将在自此起最多15天内遭到敌人的攻击。据说洛林公爵（Duke of Lorraine）等人已经集结了5万军队，当他们全军会合时，人数将不少于10万人甚至更多。那是威廉·巴尔多夫（William Bardolph），加来的副总督，他写信给亨利五世的弟弟贝德福德公爵（Duke of Bedford），听众可能还记得他被留下来
behind to run England. And he is writing to him on the 7th of October, the day before Henry V sets out from Hafler on this very risky march all the way to Calais. And Tom, obviously these numbers, like basically all numbers before about 1700, are kind of made up, massively exaggerated. But what that letter captures is this sense that Henry is taking a hell of a gamble because the French undoubtedly have a much bigger force. There are all these reports coming in of French troops assembling. What is he thinking? What's he playing at? Right. So Henry's objective, as we said in the first half, his aim is to march from Havle to Calais. And there's a priest in Henry's train. We've already quoted
负责管理英格兰。他在10月7日写信给他，也就是亨利五世从阿夫勒尔出发进行这趟通往加来的极度危险的行军的前一天。汤姆，很明显，这些数字——就像1700年以前的所有数字一样——都是胡编乱造的，被大大夸大了。但那封信捕捉到了这样一种感觉：亨利在进行一场豪赌，因为法国人无疑拥有更强大的兵力。不断有关于法军集结的各种报告传来。他在想什么？他在玩什么把戏？好吧。所以亨利的目标，正如我们在上半部分所说，他的目标是从阿夫勒尔行军到加来。亨利随行人员中有一位神父——我们已经引述过
him and he provides a kind of an eyewitness account of this expedition. And he says in his account that the direct route from Harfleur to Calais is about a hundred miles, but Henry knows better. He knows that it's 150 miles. He's expecting that this will take eight days to cover and this should be doable. So Henry is leaving the sick behind. He's not that this will take eight days to cover. And this should be doable. So Henry is leaving the sick behind. He's not taking them with him. Because there's only about 6,000 men, they can use all their horses. So essentially, they'll be riding rather than walking.
他了，他提供了这次远征的目击记述。他在记述中说，从阿夫勒尔到加来的直线距离大约是100英里，但亨利心知肚明。他知道那是150英里。他预计这将花八天时间走完，这应该是可行的。所以亨利把病号留下了。他没有
And because Henry is not planning to lay siege to any castles or towns, there's no need to bring the cannon. There is, however, of course, a need to bring large quantities of arrows because Henry, as a young man at the Battle of Shrewsbury, had fought against Hotspur and Hotspur's archers had run out of arrows and that had doomed him. So Henry, having brought all these archers, does not want to be in a situation where the firepower runs out. And are they taking food with them? I mean, this is key, right? They think it'll take eight days. Do they have eight days worth of
把他们带在身边。因为只有大约6,000人，他们可以使用所有的马匹。所以基本上，他们会骑马而不是步行。由于亨利不打算围攻任何城堡或城镇，因此无需携带大炮。然而，当然需要携带大量的箭矢，因为亨利年轻时在什鲁斯伯里战役（Battle of Shrewsbury）中曾与热刺交过手，当时热刺的弓箭手射光了箭矢，这注定了他的命运。所以亨利既然带了这么多弓箭手，就不想陷入火力耗尽的境地。他们随身携带食物吗？我的意思是，这是关键，对吧？他们认为需要八天时间。他们随身带了够吃八天的食物吗？
food to take with them? They do. So this is the assumption. It will take eight days. And so they take eight days worth of food. And again, because traditionally English armies going through France had, you know, they'd done what were called chevauchee, great plundering sweeps through the French countryside. Henry is making his march as someone who thinks he is the king of France. And so he is not prepared to allow that. And so this is why he is taking food with him. He doesn't want his men going out and plundering and raping or whatever.
他们带了。所以这就是设想。需要八天时间。所以他们带了够吃八天的食物。同样，由于传统的英格兰军队穿过法国时，你知道的，他们会进行所谓的“骑兵劫掠”（chevauchee），在法国乡村进行大肆烧杀掠夺的扫荡。亨利把他的行军当作一个自认为自己是法国国王的人来指挥。因此他不愿意允许这种事发生。这就是为什么他随身携带食物。他不想让他的手下去外面大肆抢劫、强奸或别的什么。
But if anything goes wrong, he doesn't have more than eight days food, does he? No, he doesn't. He doesn't. And so this then focuses the challenge for the French. The French have the problem that it's Henry who's setting out. And so to begin with, he has the initiative. The French can't know where Henry is going to be going, but they do know that if Henry is to reach Calais, he's going to have to cross the River Somme, which is quite a broad river, quite hard for a large expedition to cross. And an army trying
但如果出了什么差错，他手头的食物绝对不超过八天，对吧？是的，确实不超过。这就把对法国人的挑战聚焦了。法国人面临的问题是，是亨利在主动出发。所以一开始，他掌握着主动权。法国人无法知道亨利要去哪里，但他们确实知道，如果亨利要到达加来，他将不得不穿过索姆河（River Somme），这是一条相当宽阔的河，一支庞大的远征军很难渡过。试图渡河的军队
to cross a river is always incredibly vulnerable. And so the French strategy is to essentially block any of the obvious crossing points and force Henry either to advance under attack across the river or to go inland to try and find a fording place, which then means, of course, that it will take him much longer than he'd been planning to. And also he will be going further and further away from Calais. So this is their plan. And their immediate target is a place called Blanchetac, which is a ford. It's just a few miles down from where the Somme meets the Channel. And it was so named after the white stones that marked it, so Blanchetac. And this is where Edward III had crossed the Somme on his expedition, which then culminated in the Battle of Crecy. So it has a
总是极其脆弱的。因此，法国人的战略基本上是封锁任何显而易见的渡口，迫使亨利要么在遭受攻击的情况下强渡索姆河，要么深入内陆寻找涉渡地点，当然，这意味着这会比他计划的花费更多的时间。而且他也会离加来越来越远。这就是他们的计划。他们的直接目标是一个叫布朗什塔克（Blanchetac）的地方，那是一个浅滩。它就在索姆河汇入海峡下游几英里处。它因标志着它的白石而得名，所以叫布朗什塔克。这也是爱德华三世在其远征途中渡过索姆河的地方，那次远征最终以克雷西战役（Battle of Crecy）告终。所以在英法战争的历史中，它扮演着
kind of resonant role in the history of the wars of the French and the English. And it's very useful because people can cross 12 men abreast there. It would be a quick crossing. And so the French assume that this is where Henry will try and make his crossing. And Dalbray, the constable who'd been in Rouen with the Dauphin, he marches at top speed to this ford with 6,000 men and they fortify the far bank and block the passage with stakes. And meanwhile, other contingents, they're fanning out down the length of the Somme and they're demolishing bridges, smashing up causeways, trying to make it very, very difficult for Henry to cross the river.
具有共鸣意义的角色。而且它非常有用，因为人们可以在那里排成12人并肩过河。这将是一次快速的渡河。所以法国人认为亨利会试图在这里渡河。阿尔布雷——曾与王太子一起在鲁昂的统帅——率领6,000人以最高速度行军到这个浅滩，他们加固了对岸，并用木桩封锁了通道。与此同时，其他部队正沿着索姆河全长呈扇形展开，他们拆毁桥梁，砸毁堤道，试图让亨利渡河变得非常非常困难。
So that will push him south. If he can't cross, he will have to turn to his right and march up the River Somme, south into the heart of France, try and find a crossing place. And of course, he will run out of food and they'll be able to surround and kill him. Exactly. And it is a massive problem for Henry because absolutely Blanchetac, this ford near the sea, is exactly where he is hoping to cross and he approaches it and they capture a prisoner and this prisoner says you know your majesty um the far side is uh is fortified it's got stakes it's got dalbray it's got six thousand men uh you you know you don't want to cross it and henry isn't a hundred certain that he believes this. So he continues
所以这会把他往南逼。如果他无法渡河，他就必须向右转，沿着索姆河向上游进军，一路向南进入法国腹地，设法寻找一个渡口。当然，他的食物会耗尽，他们将能够包围并消灭他。完全正确。这对亨利来说是一个巨大的难题，因为绝对地，布朗舍塔克，这个靠近大海的浅滩，正是他希望渡河的地方。当他靠近那里时，他们抓获了一个俘虏，而这个俘虏说，你知道，陛下，嗯，对岸是，呃，有防 fortifications（有防御工事），有木桩，有拒马，有六千人，呃，你知道的，你肯定不想从那儿过。而亨利并不是百分之百确信他相信这一点。所以他继续
to interview the prisoner. And at the end of the interview, he's been convinced. He thinks, yes, the prisoner is telling the truth. And so he halts the march. He summons his magnates and they have a council of war and they debate for a couple of hours and then they decide we can't risk it. You know, we'll be slaughtered if they really are there. We've got no choice but to start marching up river. There's no question at that point of turning back to our floor. No, it's an interesting one. They don't. I, because I think it would be too great a humiliation. So now instead of doing that, they take this mad gamble really of saying we're going to turn in inland into the heart of france well i
盘问这个俘虏。在盘问结束时，他被说服了。他想，是的，这个俘虏说的是实话。于是他下令停止行军。他召集了他的贵族们，他们召开了军事会议，讨论了几个小时，然后他们决定我们不能冒这个险。你知道的，如果他们真的在那里，我们会被屠杀的。我们别无选择，只能开始沿着河往上游行军。在那一点上，根本没有退回我们来时的浅滩的问题。不，这是一个有趣的选择。他们没有这么做。我，因为我认为那会是太大的羞辱了。所以现在他们没有那样做，而是冒了一个真正的疯狂之险，说我们要向内陆转向法国腹地。嗯，我
think that's the measure of both henry's determination not to be humiliated on the stage of france and indeed of christendom and also his you know his inner confidence this is such alexander the great behavior i think as of course in shakespeare's play the welsh captain fluellen likewise compares henry v to alexander that's uh that's the welsh blood speaking to you tom I think. As of course, in Shakespeare's play, the Welsh captain Flewellyn, likewise, compares Henry V to Alexander. That's the Welsh blood speaking to you, Tom. Absolutely. So as you say, this is very, very bad for morale because Henry's men, they know that they haven't got much food. They're now having to march inland away from Calais and they can't be sure that they're going to find a
认为这既衡量了亨利决不在法国舞台乃至整个基督教世界面前受辱的决心，也衡量了他内心的自信。这太像亚历山大大帝的行径了，我想，正如莎士比亚戏剧中的威尔士船长弗鲁埃伦一样，也将亨利五世比作亚历山大。呃，那是威尔士血统在跟你说话，汤姆，我想。正如莎士比亚戏剧中的威尔士船长弗鲁埃伦一样，也将亨利五世比作亚历山大。呃，那是威尔士血统在跟你说话，汤姆。完全正确。所以正如你所说，这对士气非常非常糟糕，因为亨利的手下知道他们的食物不多了。他们现在不得不向内陆行军，远离加来，而且他们无法确定自己是否能找到一个
crossing point. So this is all very, very alarming. And what's even more unsettling for them as they start to get a bit peckish is that Henry continues to uphold the ordinances of war. He is still not going to allow them to plunder and to loot and to strip the cottages and the villages of his French subjects of their food. And to impose this, he instructs that only certain officers can have dealings with the French. So in other words, there's going to be a clear chain of communication that he could control. He's not having people just fanning out. And as a marker of his absolute determination to uphold these rules, when one of his soldiers steals a silver fitting from a church, this guy is publicly hanged. And in Shakespeare's play, this is a character called Bardolph, who was one of Henry V's drinking companions.
渡口。所以这一切都非常非常令人担忧。而当他们开始觉得有点饿时，更让他们感到不安的是，亨利继续执行战争条例。他仍然不允许他们掠夺、抢劫，不允许他们洗劫法国臣民的小屋和村庄的食物。为了强行推行这一点，他指示只有特定的官员才能与法国人打交道。换句话说，将会有清晰的、他可以控制的通信链。他绝不允许人们只是四处散开。作为他坚决执行这些规则的绝对决心的标志，当他的一名士兵从一座教堂里偷走了一个银制配件时，这家伙被公开绞死了。在莎士比亚的戏剧中，这个角色叫巴多夫，他曾是亨利五世的酒友之一。
One of Falstaff's cronies. When he was Prince Hal. Yeah, he was Falstaff's cronies. Back when he was Prince Hal. Yeah, he was Falstaff's servant. And in the Kenneth Branagh film, he's played by Richard Bryars, who is the hero of The Good Life, who I think you wrote about, didn't you? I have written about The Good Life.
法斯塔夫的死党之一。当他是哈尔王子的时候。是的，他是法斯塔夫的死党。早在他是哈尔王子的时候。是的，他是法斯塔夫的仆人。在肯尼思·布拉纳的电影中，他由理查德·布赖尔斯饰演，他就是《美好生活》的男主角，我想你写过关于这部剧的文章，对吧？我确实写过《美好生活》。
Though for me, Richard Bryars' best role was in Ever-Decreasing Circles, Tom. You were not wrong. You were not wrong. So anyway, so poor Richard Bryars gets hanged. And this is all about upholding discipline. Henry also insists that every English soldier should wear the cross of St. George so that they can be identified.
不过对我来说，理查德·布赖尔斯最好的角色是在《渐入佳境》里，汤姆。你没说错。你没说错。所以无论如何，可怜的理查德·布赖尔斯被绞死了。这一切都是为了维护纪律。亨利还坚持每个英国士兵都应该佩戴圣乔治十字架，以便能够被识别出来。
And discipline is very, very strict. And Dominic, I'm proud, proud to say that even the French acknowledge this. Saw this. This brought tears to my eyes, actually. It's wonderful. So a French chronicler says, Henry always observed proper and honourable practices. And there's another French chronicler
而且纪律非常非常严格。多米尼克，我很自豪地、自豪地说，连法国人都承认这一点。看到了这一点。这实际上让我感动得流泪了。太棒了。所以一位法国编年史家说，亨利总是遵守得体和光荣的做法。还有另一位法国编年史家
who contrasts the behaviour of the English, who are notorious in France for the brutality of their chevauchée. But they say that this time, no, they behaved very well. And it's the French who behave badly as they're kind of charging across Normandy to try and block off all these crossing points on the Somme and they did nothing according to this
将英国人的行为与法国人进行了对比，英国人在法国以其骑兵劫掠的残暴而闻名。但他们说这一次，没有，他们表现得很好。反而是法国人在争先恐后地穿过诺曼底、试图封锁索姆河上所有这些渡口时表现得很糟糕，根据这位编年史家的说法，他们除了抢劫和洗劫城镇、修道院和隐修院以及强暴妇女之外什么也没做。
chronicler save robbing and pillaging towns monasteries and abbeys and violating women. Plus ça change Tom I mean that basically set the tone for the next 600 years didn't it? I think the most ringing endorsement of the behaviour of the English on this march is given by Anne Currie who it's fair to say is not team Henry V, but even she acknowledges that the overall impression is that the English were better disciplined. That's coming from a herald. It's coming from a herald, so she'd know. Yeah.
太阳底下无新事，汤姆。我的意思是，这基本上为接下来的600年定下了基调，不是吗？我认为对英国人在这次行军中的行为最响亮的赞誉是由安·柯里给出的，公平地说，她并不是亨利五世的粉丝，但连她也承认，总体印象是英国人的纪律更好。这是来自一位纹章官的评价。这是来自一位纹章官的评价，所以她很清楚。是的。
Yes. So I think all English listeners can feel very proud of that. So hooray for Henry. But of course, none of this helps them cross the Somme and none of this helps them stay well fed. And so as they march along the line of the Somme, they're getting more and more depressed. And what adds to their sense of depression is the realisation that they're being shadowed on the other side of the river. So at this point, they can see the French. They have a sense of them. Well, they either see them or they, you know, Henry has spies who are bringing in news. And these spies report that these French armies are being led by D'Abré and by Boussico, who are the two greatest soldiers in France.
是的。所以我想所有英国听众都可以为此感到非常骄傲。所以为亨利欢呼。但是，当然，这一切都无法帮助他们渡过索姆河，这一切也无法帮助他们吃饱饭。因此，当他们沿着索姆河一线行军时，他们越来越沮丧。加剧他们沮丧感的是他们意识到河对岸有人在尾随他们。所以在这个时候，他们可以看到法国人。他们对他们有所察觉。嗯，要么他们看到了他们，要么，你知道的，亨利有间谍不断带回消息。这些间谍报告说，这些法国军队由达布雷和布西科率领，他们是法国最伟大的两名军人。
So they clearly mean business. And so we have a brilliant account of how it felt for them that comes from this chaplain in Henry's train. And he writes, at the time, we thought of nothing else but this, that after the eight days assigned for the march had expired and our provisions had run out, the enemy craftily hasting on ahead and laying waste the countryside in advance would impose on us, hungry as we should be, a really dire need of food. And at the head of the river, if God did not provide otherwise, would, with their great and countless host and the engines of war and devices available to them overwhelm us so very few as we were and made faint by great weariness and weak from lack of food so you know not not a cheery
所以他们显然是来真的。因此，我们有了一份精彩的记述，讲述了他们当时的感受，这段文字来自亨利随军的一位牧师。他写道：当时我们只想到了这一点，那就是在为行军指定的八天期限过去、我们的给养耗尽之后，敌人狡猾地抢先赶到并提前破坏了乡村，将使我们这些饥肠辘辘的人陷入对食物的真正极度渴望中；在河的源头，如果上帝没有另作安排，将会用他们庞大无数的军队、战争机器和他们可用的装置，来压倒我们这寥寥无几的人，使我们因极度的疲惫而虚弱，因缺乏食物而力竭。所以，你知道的，这绝不是一个令人振奋的
state of play and it comes to seem worse and worse the deeper and deeper into france they go so three days go by four days five days since their failure to ford the Somme at Blanchetac. And then finally, at dawn on the 19th of October, at last, the English get the news that they've been waiting for. There's not one ford ahead, there are two. And it's unclear how they're discovered, but it's likely that Henry gets told about them by a kind of local who wants the English off his lands. These fords are going to be perilous to cross because they have to be approached through a marsh. And obviously for an army to go through a marsh, that's very vulnerable. And the causeways have been smashed up.
局势，而且他们深入法国腹地越深，情况就显得越糟糕。于是三天过去了，四天，五天，自从他们在布朗舍塔克未能渡过索姆河以来。最后，在10月19日的黎明，英国人终于得到了他们一直等待的消息。前方不是只有一个浅滩，而是有两个。目前还不清楚它们是如何被发现的，但很可能是某个希望英国人离开他土地的当地人把这些浅滩告诉了亨利。渡过这些浅滩将是危险的，因为必须穿过一片沼泽才能接近它们。显然，对于一支军队来说，穿过一片沼泽是非常脆弱的。而且堤道已经被砸毁了。
So Boussica had been there earlier and his men had kind of smashed them up. But it was still possible with difficulty and in a single file. But the opposite bank is not guarded. So if the luck of the English holds, if no French forces come while they're engaged in this operation to cross the Somme, they will be able to get across. Why is it not guarded? Because the French think they've smashed the causeways and therefore... Because the Somme is so long, there are so many potential crossing points. Okay.
所以布西科之前去过那里，他的人把它们砸毁了。但尽管困难重重，单列纵队还是可以通行的。不过对岸并没有人防守。如果英国人的运气够好，如果在他们进行渡过索姆河的行动时没有法国军队赶来，他们就能够成功过河。为什么没有人防守？因为法国人认为他们已经砸毁了堤道，所以……因为索姆河太长了，有太多潜在的渡口。好吧。
You know, they're scattered. So it's absolutely a moment of excruciating danger. And Henry knows this, but he also knows he has no choice. So what happens is he orders some of his archers in the vanguard to go first. And they get their bows, they get their quivers, they hold them up over their heads. They don't want their bowstrings to get wet. And they cross and then they take up a position on the far bank to protect those who are going to be following them.
你知道的，他们分散了。所以这绝对是一个极其危险的时刻。亨利深知这一点，但他也知道自己别无选择。于是发生的事情是，他命令先锋部队的一些弓箭手打头阵。他们拿着弓，拿着箭筒，把它们高举过头顶。他们不想让弓弦弄湿。他们渡过河，然后远岸占据一个阵位，以保护那些将要跟随他们过河的人。
The men-at-arms follow, and then the horses of the vanguard. So to be clear, of course, most men have not been travelling on horseback. They've been just trudging. Yeah, most people have been riding on horseback. Oh, sorry. They have been. Yeah, there have been enough horses for them to be doing that. So the horses are important because it expedites their speed. So once the vanguard is across, you've got the archers,
武装人员随后跟进，接着是先锋部队的马匹。需要说明的是，当然，大多数人并不是骑马旅行的。他们一直在艰难跋涉。是的，大多数人一直在骑马。哦，抱歉。他们一直在骑马。是的，有足够的马匹让他们这样做。所以马匹很重要，因为它加快了他们的速度。一旦先锋部队过河，你就有了弓箭手，
you've got the men-at-arms, they are then in a position to hold off an attacking force. And while they've been crossing, everybody else has been kind of smashing up local settlements, taking the rubble, using it to build up the causeway so that it can then be crossed. And by one o'clock in the afternoon, so it's taken them the wholeble, using it to build up the causeway so that it can then be crossed. And by one o'clock in the afternoon, so it's taken them the whole morning, the causeways can be negotiated by three men marching abreast and the full scale operation happens. And Henry risks dividing up his army.
你有了武装人员，他们就处于能够阻挡进攻部队的位置了。而在他们过河的同时，其他人则一直在砸毁当地的定居点，取下瓦砾，用它们来加固堤道，以便随后可以通过。到了下午一点钟，也就是说他们花了整个早上的时间，堤道已经可以容纳三个人并肩行军了，全方位的行动随即展开。而亨利冒险分兵了。
So the body of men cross one of the causeways, the luggage train with all the arrows and supplies and everything crosses the other. And they make it across, even though while they're doing it, a squad of French horsemen do ride up and observe them, but they realise that they haven't got enough men to attack Henry's force. And so it is an amazing feat to pull this off. And English morale surges correspondingly. And the chaplain is so excited about it that he thinks the way to Calais is now open. And that the news that the English have made it across, in despite of all the French, this will be so demoralising for the French, their morale will plummet. And in the words of the chaplain, they will be disinclined to follow after us to
一部分人通过其中一条堤道过河，装载着所有箭矢、补给品和其他一切的辎重车队通过另一条堤道过河。他们成功过河了，尽管在他们过河的时候，一队法国骑兵确实骑马过来观察了他们，但他们意识到自己没有足够的人数来进攻亨利的部队。因此，完成这一壮举简直令人惊叹。英国人的士气也随之大涨。牧师对此兴奋不已，他认为通往加来的道路现在已经敞开了。而且，英国人在克服了法国人的种种阻挠后成功过河的消息，将对法国人造成极大的打击，他们的士气将一落千丈。用牧师的话来说，他们将不愿意尾随我们而来进行
do battle. But unfortunately for him and for the rest of the English, the opposite is actually the case. Because once the English have crossed the Somme, this vast French army, they know that it's no longer their business to kind of fan out along the length of the river. They need to concentrate and block the path to Calais and engage the English in battle and hopefully wipe them out. Because in a way, although the English are across, they've basically walked into, it's not really a trap, but they've walked into the killing ground. The French army is huge, it's there, and the English now are tired.
战斗。但不幸的是，对于他以及其余的英国人来说，实际情况恰恰相反。因为一旦英国人渡过了索姆河，这支庞大的法国军队就知道，沿着河流散开不再是他们的职责了。他们需要集中力量，封锁通往加来的道路，与英国人交战，并希望能彻底消灭他们。因为某种程度上，尽管英国人已经过河了，但他们基本上走进了一个——虽然不是真正的陷阱，但他们走进了杀戮区。法国军队庞大无比，他们就在那里，而英国人现在已经疲惫不堪。
Yeah, they're hungry. Yeah, hungry. They're famished, they're wet. Exactly, exactly. I mean, it's like a kind of imagine a you know a 10-day walking holiday in the lake district where you're completely lost just rains all the time you haven't got any food and then you've got to fight at the end and then you've got to fight the french yeah so here's the thing the constable is there the guy alonso
是的，他们饿了。是的，饿了。他们饿极了，湿漉漉的。没错，没错。我的意思是，这就像是一个——想象一下你在湖区进行了一次为期10天的徒步旅行，完全迷路了，一路上都在下雨，没有任何食物，然后在最后你还得打一仗，然后你还得和法国人打仗。是的，所以情况是这样的，统帅在那里，那个叫阿隆索的
the bruiser is there busicoadin. Yeah, he's there. What about the Dauphin? Because you said the Dauphin was, dare I say, too fat to fight. The Dauphin, so there's this great council of war where all these various magnates are in attendance. It's held on the 19th of October, which of course is the same day that the English are crossing the Somme. And it's agreed that if the English do manage to get across,
恶霸在那里，布西科在那里。是的，他也在那里。那王太子呢？因为你曾说过王太子，恕我直言，胖得都不能打仗了。王太子——所以有一场盛大的军事会议，所有这些大大小小的贵族都出席了。它于10月19日举行，这当然也是英国人渡过索姆河的同一天。会议达成一致，如果英国人确实设法过了河，
then they will give battle. And as many men as possible will be summoned. So they shouldn't rush into fighting the English do manage to get across, then they will give battle and as many men as possible will be summoned. So they shouldn't rush into fighting the English immediately that they cross the river. They should try and get as many people as possible to make the odds absolutely overwhelming, but that they should definitely fight. Now, what will be the role of the Dauphin or even more, you know, the king? Because ideally you want someone from the royal family to lead this expedition. It's decided that the king obviously is in no state. He's made of glass. Be mad to put him in a battle. You don't want him shattering. The Dauphin, as you say, is a bit podgy,
那么他们将进行交战。并且将尽可能多地召集人员。所以他们不应该急于跟成功过河的英国人开战。他们应该尽量召集更多的人，让兵力对比绝对呈现压倒性优势，但他们绝对应该开战。现在，王太子甚至更重要的国王，将扮演什么角色呢？因为理想情况下，你希望王室成员来领导这次远征。人们决定，国王显然状况不佳。他是玻璃做的。把他弄进战场就太疯狂了。你可不想看他粉碎。王太子，正如你所说，有点胖墩墩的，
but that's not actually the reason I think why he doesn't go. It's because there are very vivid memories of Poitiers where the king got captured and that bled France dry. They don't want to risk any prospect of the king or the Dauphin being captured and then having to be ransomed. But there's also a more immediate and vivid reason, which is that the vast proportion of people in this council of war are from the Armagnac faction. And so they are worried about John the Fearless because Henry is about to advance into Burgundian territory and they don't trust the Duke of Burgundy necessarily to be on their side. And so the Dauphin will stay behind and he will be in command of troops that will
但这实际上并不是我认为他没有去的原因。原因是对普瓦捷战役有着非常清晰的记忆，当时国王被俘，这让法国元气大伤。他们不想冒国王或王太子被俘然后不得不支付巨额赎金的任何风险。但还有一个更直接、更生动的原因，那就是参加这次军事会议绝大多数人都是阿马尼亚克派系成员。因此，他们对无畏的约翰感到担忧，因为亨利即将推进到勃艮第领地，他们不信任勃艮第公爵一定会站在他们这边。所以王太子将留在后面，他将指挥的军队本质上将在巴黎和勃艮第公爵的军队之间充当一道屏障。当他在集结军队时，参加这次军事会议的人们在想，这是为了进攻英国人，还是为了进攻巴黎？
essentially serve as a screen between Paris and the forces of the Duke of Burgundy. As he's raising men, the people in this council of war are wondering, is it to attack the English or is it to attack Paris? So the Burgundians have raised an army, but they haven't joined with the Armenecs, and they're just sort of waiting. Are they waiting to see who wins? So the shadow of the civil war between the Dukes of Orléans and Burgundy continues to be a massive problem for the French, even with Henry on their doorstep. So because the King and the Dauphin are not going to be present with this army, it's important to have a member of the royal family. And so the Duke of Orléans goes. He's been preparing for his 21st birthday party. So he's
所以勃艮第人组建了一支军队，但他们没有与阿马尼亚克人联合，他们只是在观望。他们是在等看谁能赢吗？所以奥尔良公爵与勃艮第公爵之间的内战阴影继续成为法国人的巨大难题，即便亨利已经兵临城下。因此，既然国王和王太子不会出席这支军队，那么拥有一位王室成员就显得非常重要了。于是奥尔良公爵去了。他一直在准备他的21岁生日派对。所以他
due to be 21 on the 26th of October. So he's obviously been kind of hanging around, getting ready, you know, hiring the disco and all that kind of thing. And then he gets a summons, no, you've got to come. So he comes galloping up. But of course, his arrival means that there's no way the Duke of Burgundy is going to join them. And actually, neither the Duke nor the Duke of Lorraine, who was mentioned
本应在10月26日迎来21岁生日。所以他显然一直在闲晃，做准备，你知道的，雇迪斯科舞厅以及所有诸如此类的事情。然后他收到了征召令，不，你必须来。于是他快马加鞭赶来。但是，当然，他的到来意味着勃艮第公爵绝不可能加入他们。实际上，公爵本人以及洛林公爵都没有来，洛林公爵在前半部分结束时你宣读的加来副指挥官的信中被提及过，人们曾担心他会带着庞大的军队前来。他也没有来，因为他是勃艮第公爵的盟友；勃艮第公爵的儿子、未来的菲利普好人也没有来。
by the Lieutenant of Calais, the reading that you gave at the beginning of this half, and it's feared that he'll be coming with vast forces. He doesn't arrive either because he's an ally of the Duke of Burgundy and nor does the Duke of Burgundy's son, the future Philip the Good, he doesn't arrive either. And this will become a cause of great shame to both John the Fearless and to Philip the Good, the fact that they weren't at Agincourt. And John the Fearless subsequently will explain this by saying that he had been forbidden by the king and by the royal council to come. I mean, it may be plausible, and it's certainly the case that his two brothers, so the Duke of Brabant and the Count of Nevers, do ride to battle.
这将成为无畏的约翰和菲利普好人心中巨大的耻辱之源——他们没有出席阿金库尔战役的事实。无畏的约翰此后将对此解释说，他曾被国王和皇家委员会禁止前来。我的意思是，这可能是合乎情理的，而且确实他的两个兄弟，即布拉班特公爵和讷韦尔伯爵，确实骑马去参加了战斗。
And lots of his kind of liegemen, his bannermen from Picardy, which is the region that Enra will be marching through, they do go as well. So it's not like there are no one from the Burgundian side present at Agincourt. But I think that John the Fearless is deliberately sitting it out because obviously if the Armagnacs get wiped out, if maybe the Duke of Orleans will be killed in battle, this would all be great for him and he would then be in pole position to capitalise on it. So I think that that's why he's not present. And of course, for a council of war that is dominated by the Armagnacs, I mean, this isn't bad news. They don't want him turning up because they don't want to share the glory of the victory
而且他的许多部下，他来自皮卡第的旗队——也就是恩拉将要行军穿过的地区——也确实去了。所以并不是说勃艮第这一方没有人出席阿金库尔战役。但我认为无畏的约翰是在故意作壁上观，因为很显然，如果阿马尼亚克人被消灭了，如果奥尔良公爵在战斗中阵亡了，这对他的大有好处，他将处于利用这一局势的绝佳位置。所以我觉得这就是他没有出席的原因。当然，对于一个由阿马尼亚克人主导的军事会议来说，我的意思是，这并不是坏消息。他们不希望他出现，因为他们不想分享胜利的荣耀，
and they don't want the risk of him, I mean, he might be in negotiations with Henry. And they have enough men, right? How many men do they have by this point? We will come to this in the next episode when we look at the actual battle because it is a topic of more debate now than it has been for several centuries. Okay. But they definitely have more than Henry V. They definitely have more. And spoiler alert, I think they have substantially more. Okay. But it is more of a live debate than it has been for a while, as I say. So we'll talk about it. But yeah, they have a large force. And so therefore they are pretty
他们也不想冒他可能与亨利进行谈判的风险。而且他们有足够的人手，对吧？到这个时候他们有多少人？我们将在下一集审视实际战斗时讨论这个问题，因为相比过去几个世纪，现在这是一个更具争议的话题。好吧。但他们的兵力绝对比亨利五世多。他们的兵力绝对更多。剧透一下，我认为他们的兵力要多得多。好吧。但这比前段时间更有争议性，正如我所说。所以我们会讨论它。不过，是的，他们拥有一支庞大的军队。因此，他们对胜利相当
confident of victory. They have more than sufficient numbers to do the job. And so the day after this council of war, the 20th of October, they send a herald to ride to Henry and to formally issue him with a challenge to battle. So this is kind of very Arthurian. This is chivalry and all that kind of thing. And Henry, like the chivalrous knight that he is, he receives this herald very graciously and he sends a herald of his own back to the French. And the message that this herald delivers, it is not necessary to pick a day nor a place, for every day they could find him in the open fields without any difficulty. In other words, you know, if you want it, come and
有信心。他们拥有绰绰有余的兵力来完成任务。于是，在这场军事会议的第二天，即10月20日，他们派遣了一名纹章官去找亨利，正式向他下达战书。所以这非常有亚瑟王传奇的色彩。这是骑士精神和所有诸如此类的事情。亨利作为一个富有骑士精神的骑士，非常亲切地接待了这名纹章官，并派出了他自己的一名纹章官回到法国人那里。这名纹章官传达的信息是：既不需要挑选日子，也不需要挑选地点，因为每一天他们都可以在开阔的田野里毫无困难地找到他。换句话说，你知道的，如果你想要，那就来
get it. And so from this point on, he orders all his men to wear the coats of arms on their circuits if they're entitled to do this. And this is a signal to the French that they are ready to fight. They are ready for combat. But in the meanwhile, they continue their march towards Calais. The road is now direct. There are no real kind of impediments. And they do it expecting the French to attack them at any moment. They are becoming increasingly nervous. The surge of morale that had followed the crossing of the Somme is starting to subside. And then their mood of anxiety is absolutely heightened by a time where they're going along the road and suddenly they see ahead of them that the road has been completely
拿吧。从这一刻起，他命令他手下的所有人，如果他们有资格这样做的话，就在他们的军服外衣上佩戴纹章。这是向法国人发出一个信号，表明他们已经准备好战斗了。他们已经准备好迎战了。但与此同时，他们继续向加来进军。道路现在很直接。没有什么真正的障碍。他们这样做时，预计法国人随时会向他们发起进攻。他们变得越来越紧张。过完索姆河后涌现的士气高涨开始消退。接着，当他们走在路上时，突然看到前方的道路被彻底
churned up. They can see that a massive force has gone ahead of them. And they realise that this must be the French forces under Dalbray and Boussico, the two great leaders of the French force, who are looking for a suitable place to offer battle. And so that at some point in the next day, maybe the day after that, they're going to find the French army drawn across the road to Calais is going to be impassable. But for three days after that, they continue marching northwards. The conditions are completely grim. There's icy rain, gusting winds. Their food supplies now are really, really low. They're all feeling really, really hungry. And the terrain is
翻耕破坏了，他们的焦虑情绪绝对达到了顶峰。他们可以看出有一支庞大的军队走在了他们前面。他们意识到这必定是达布雷和布西科率领的法国军队——法国军队的两大领袖——他们正在寻找一个合适的地方来提供交战。所以在接下来的某一天，也许是后天，他们会发现横亘在通往加来的道路上的法国军队将是无法通过的。但在那之后的三天里，他们继续向北行军。天气条件简直糟透了。有冰冷的雨，阵风。他们的食物供应现在真的、真的很少了。他们都觉得非常、非常饿。地形也
becoming increasingly kind of hilly. They're having to go up and down, up and down. And a lot of them are ill, aren't they, at this point? They have colds or dysentery or whatever, don't they? No, I don't think they're too ill. It's not like Harfleur. I mean, of course, you know, some are, but no, I think they're despondent and wet and miserable and hungry, but they're still kind of just about in a fit state to fight a battle. But their hope is actually, you know, as the days pass and they still don't run into the French, maybe they'll do it. So by the 24th of October, they're only about 40 miles from Calais. I mean, they can almost feel that they're there. And on the 24th of October, early morning,
变得越来越丘陵起伏。他们不得不上上下下，上上下下。而且在这个时候，他们当中有很多人都生病了，对吧？他们得了感冒或痢疾什么的，对吧？不，我不认为他们病得太厉害。这不像阿尔夫勒尔。我的意思是，当然，你知道的，有些人病了，但是，不，我认为他们只是沮丧、湿漉漉的、悲惨而饥饿，但他们仍然勉强处于能够打仗的状态。不过他们的希望实际上是，你知道的，随着日子一天天过去，他们仍然没有撞上法国人，也许他们能成功通过。所以在10月24日，他们距离加来只有大约40英里。我的意思是，他们几乎能感觉到自己已经到了。而在10月24日清晨，
the English are descending into a river valley and ahead of them is a river called the Ternoise. It's not a massive river, but you don't want to be caught crossing it. So they're coming down towards the river when Henry's scouts come galloping up and they say, Your Majesty, alarming news. There are large numbers of French gathering in the road about three miles beyond the river. And it looks like this is what we've been waiting for. They are massing there and they are ready to offer battle. And for Henry, this is alarming news because he's got to get across this river. The Ford may be held against him. Even if it isn't, if the French attack him while he's crossing this river, that would be
英国人正在下坡进入一个河谷，前方是一条名为泰尔努瓦的河流。这不是一条大河，但你可不想被困在渡河时。所以他们正朝着河边走去，这时亨利的侦探们快马加鞭地赶来，他们说：“陛下，有令人担忧的消息。有大量的法国人正聚集在河外大约三英里处的路上。看起来这就是我们一直在等待的时刻。他们正在那里集结，随时准备迎战。”对亨利来说，这是一个令人担忧的消息，因为他必须过河。浅滩可能会被敌人把守。即使没有，如果法国人在他过河时进攻他，那将是
not ideal. So he turns to his men and he says, onwards, we've got to make full steam ahead. So they hurry down towards the river. Huge relief. They find that the Ford is not held against them. They cross the river at top speed and then they march up the hill again towards the crest of the next ridge. And they reach the crest of the hill. And at the top of the hill, they gaze at the vista that they see before them and
很不理想的。于是他转向他的人民说：“前进，我们必须全速前进。”于是他们急忙向河边赶去。巨大的解脱。他们发现浅滩没有被敌人把守。他们以最快的速度渡过河，然后再次向山坡上行军，朝着下一个山脊的顶峰前进。他们到达了山顶。在山顶上，他们凝视着眼前的景色，
the sight is a terrifying one and i quote about half a mile away the grim looking ranks of the french and these ranks are being added to all the time as they stand there on the ridge, the English can see ever more squadrons of French marching in, riding in, swelling the numbers of the army that is blocking the road to Calais. And Henry asks his spies, these two villages ahead of us, I can see that the French are kind of massing there around them. What are the names of these villages? And he is told, well, one of them is called Risseville, and the other, Your Majesty, the name of this village, it is Agincourt. Well, if you want to hear what happens next right away, then you can join the Rest Is History Club at therestishistory.com. But either way, we will be back with the Battle of Agincourt.
景象令人毛骨悚然，我引述道：“大约半英里外，法国人那神情严峻的列阵……”这些列阵的人数一直在增加。当他们站在山脊上时，英国人可以看到越来越多的法国骑兵队列行进过来、骑马赶来，不断壮大着那支封锁了通往加来道路的军队的规模。亨利问他的间谍：“我们前方的那两个村庄，我可以看到法国人正聚集在它们周围。这些村庄叫什么名字？”有人告诉他：“陛下，其中一个叫里斯维尔，另一个，陛下，这个村庄的名字是阿金库尔。”好吧，如果你想立刻听到接下来发生了什么，那么你可以加入“历史就是一切”俱乐部（the rest is history club），网址是 therestishistory.com。但无论如何，我们都将带着阿金库尔战役归来。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐就是一切》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想获得无广告收听、额外单集以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。